and this brings me to my final point of
today's show these abortion bans also
highlight something else not just the
Republican Party's war on women or their
disdain for science but it's the fact
that this Republican Party as we know it
today has not had a new idea in 40 years
not one three things this Republican
Party has been pushing for the last 40
years
one cut taxes for the wealthy and let it
trickle down to the workers to cut all
regulations so businesses can do
whatever the hell they want and three
don't love women have abortions 40 years
longer than I've been on this planet by
the way they have been pushing those
same three tired and worn-out ideas that
do not work I honestly want people to
think about that fact for a moment this
is a party that hasn't had a new idea
for the entire time that the millennial
generation has been alive ever since
Reagan first came into office and
started pushing this failed theory of
trickle-down economics that was it
Reagan also ushered in the era of
deregulation that also tanked the
economy by the way and of course the
religious right who latched on to Reagan
with the anti-abortion movement but ever
since then Republicans have done nothing
to actually benefit the American public
the working class the average people out
here in this country they've done plenty
to benefit the the wealthy elite plenty
the tax cuts the deregulation all of
that benefits them the abortion thing is
just to keep their base a little drummed
up while they rob them because that's
what's happened you know we're making up
for the fact that wealthy people don't
have to pay as much in taxes you know
we're getting hosed on that
we may not be paying more because of
that some of us are actually under the
current tax pay and some of us are but
what I mean is our schools aren't
properly funded our kids are using
textbooks that are fifteen to twenty
years old we're paying higher prices for
medications we're paying for the trade
wars we're seeing college prices
skyrocket we're getting screwed over by
the big banks they robbed our pension
funds in 2007 and 2008 and got bailed
out instead of thrown in prison we've
been paying the price this whole time
for the Republicans policies and the
Democrats went along with some of these
two by the way but the only reason these
people keep voting Republican knowing
that this party hasn't had a new idea
since Reagan is because of the abortion
thing that's what keeps them coming back
you know the culture war issues that's
it when you go to the polls in 2020 I
want you to ask yourself this I hope you
ask yourself this prior to going to the
polls because you probably need to think
about it when was the last time the
Republicans had an idea that benefitted
the middle class the working class the
underclass when I mean we were told
earlier this year multiple different
times that their health care plan was
right around the corner we're gonna get
it next week they went to Camp David a
couple weekends ago to work this out and
they came up with nothing Trump told us
on Twitter hey get ready it's coming in
April
oops it didn't come in April now he says
that it's gonna come after 2020 listen
to me you're a party that's been running
on repealing Obama care for nearly ten
years you've had time to come up with a
health care policy you failed to do it
because you don't know what you're doing
if it's not a tax cut or deregulation or
an abortion you're clueless and you're
lost and that is exactly what the
Republican Party is today they're
clueless they're lost and they haven't
had a single good idea since long before
I was born
and the only ideas they've had in the
last 40 years there was three that I've
talked about
have been absolute train wrecks for the
United States look I am fair and cousins
thank you very much for tuning in today
thank you to David for letting me sit in
today I will be back tomorrow to fill in
once again in the meantime follow me on
Twitter at fair and balanced also on
Instagram and on Facebook at fair and
balanced and stay tuned for the bonus
show got a great new report from Media
Matters showing that Fox News even on
their new Z programs is still lying to
the public every day and also the GAO
says that Ben Carson definitely broke
the law I am fair and Cousins thank you
for watching the David Pakman show I'll
see you tomorrow